bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football le laissera pas réussi à tenir
en échec le leader de promotion
d'honneur à boulogne-billancourt à
domicile l'équipe n'a perdu qu'un seul
de ses huit derniers matchs le résumé tu
as eue dans quelques instants
cyclisme sur piste le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines accueille
ce dimanche la deuxième manche de la
coupe d'hiver près de 140 concurrents
participent à la compétition plus de
détails à suivre
boxe nous avons rencontré l'élan pour
toi adila hamouma dit le boxeur de la
team farruggia affrontera ce samedi
l'ukrainien shelley fall aux îlots
grampus au grand retour après avoir
perdu sa ceinture européenne en avril
dernier au plan présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end
on commence par du football est bonne ou
bonne opération pour trappe dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur les
trappistes actuellement dans le ventre
mou du classement réussi à tenir en
échec sur leur terrain
le leader boulogne billancourt le score
0 à 0 les images ont signé à nicolas
dans un match avec du rythme mais sans
but trappes n'a pas réussi à concrétiser
ses nombreuses occasions pour venir à
bout du leader boulogne billancourt sur
son terrain l'occasion de la 11e journée
de ph
la rencontre s'est terminée par un score
nul et vierge content mais peut-être un
peu de déception aussi parce qu'on a on
a fait un match sérieux appliqué
on a poussé en deuxième mi temps on a eu
la possession du ballon les occasions
mais malheureusement pas su concrétiser
on se satisfait jamais d'un match nul
parce qu'on vient pour les victoires
cela étant il ya des matches nuls qui
valent quand même un bon résultat on
joue quand même le premier de la poule
au classement trap est actuellement dans
le ventre mou du championnat à la 9e
place mais les trappistes sont dans une
dynamique positive avec une seule
défaite en huit matches disputés
autre satisfaction l'équipe est toujours
invaincu à domicile des signes
encourageants qui promettent une
deuxième partie de saison passionnante
de faire mieux qu'à la guerre on a fini
quatrième donc la chercher un podium
on a un groupe uni soudé et je pense
qu'en faisant un peu plus par sans
palier je pense que la deuxième partie
de saison pourra jouer en notre faveur
on a encore du travail c'est la saison à
va être super longue qu'une poule de 14
équipes
donc on a beaucoup de choses à
travailler pour pouvoir espérer la
reprise pour les trappistes est
programmée pour le dimanche 8 janvier
les joueurs se déplaceront sur le
terrain de puteaux 11e du championnat
on va à présent parler de cyclisme dans
ce magazine c'est une première en ile de
france les clubs franciliens ont créé la
coupe d'hiver une compétition en quatre
étapes pour aider au développement de la
discipline en région parisienne ce
dimanche la deuxième manche était
programmé au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à pascal
josèphe pour le montage du spectacle au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ce dimanche 11 décembre la
structure a accueilli la deuxième manche
de la coupe d'hiver
cette compétition composée de quatre
étapes a été créée cette année par les
clubs franciliens pour soutenir la
formation des cyclistes la piste c'est
une des bases du vélo etc on a un
magnifique bouquet ici il faut il faut
former des coureurs ya pas de mystère
au total 140 concurrents de la catégorie
minimes à la catégorie seniors se sont
affrontés dans des épreuves de vitesse
de sprint et d'endurance sont ça génial
vraiment parce que ça montre plein
l'épreuve du cyclisme et en plus si le
club monte inique organise donc moi je
suis heureux et je trouve ça vraiment
très bien c'est une bonne organisation
et je trouve ça super chouette parmi les
concurrents des têtes d'affiché l'un des
plus grands espoirs du cyclisme sur
piste mélissandre pain championne de
france du kerry nantes 2015 avait fait
le déplacement
je me suis fracturé le poignet ya deux
mois
du coup j'ai été j'ai été deux mois sans
faire de compet et on s'en faire de
sprint que avec le coach on a pensé que
c'était une bonne idée de revenir courir
et de retrouver un peu le la compétition
même si c'était pas c'est pas forcément
mais mes épreuves
au niveau international la troisième
manche de cette coupe d'hiver sera
organisé le samedi 21 janvier par le
club de clamart toujours au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des nouvelles du vendée globe le
versailles et éric bellion qui est
actuellement dans l'océan indien failli
abandonner mercredi dernier parce qu'il
part a été victime d'une avarie a dû
réparer en urgence son safran une pièce
sans carbone situé à l'arrière du bateau
après plus de onze heures de travaux le
navigateur de comme un seul homme a pu
repartir pour ce tour du monde en
solitaire on regarde la séquence ça je
peux vous dire que je suis vraiment fier
de ce combat là parce que cent fois j'ai
voulu abandonner en disant que j'y
arriverais pas
j'y suis depuis cinq heures du matin je
me suis battu et bon l'aventuré continue
je suis content et là je peux vous dire
que je me repose un peu parce que ça a
été un combat dans l'est dans les vagues
qui fait appel à vouloir hierges trempé
bon voilà donc l'aventuré continue sur
comme un seul homme mais c'est ça le
principal quelques jours après cette
épreuve le navigateur éric bellion va
mieux le versailles a mis en ligne vidéo
ce week end pour remercier ses fans qui
l'ont soutenu pendant cette épreuve
et on peut dire qu'il a retrouvé le
sourire voilà comme un seul homme qui
trace sa route plein est sur le vendée
globe
pas vraiment vous remercier de vos
messages d'encouragement pendant la case
du ca prends vraiment ça m'a vraiment
touché je voulais vous dire à quel point
le bateau et moi on est heureux de
pouvoir continuer l aventure
extraordinaire nos milieux des albatros
et on trace plein est vers l'australie
c'est génial
retour sur la terre ferme eux aussi
doivent avoir le sourire pendant leur
passage plus de 250 gymnastes ont
participé ce week end aux championnats
départementaux de gymnastique au gymnase
cosec de mort pas de compétition
organisée pour la deuxième fois
consécutive par le club local j'aime
elancourt maurepas les meilleurs
sportifs des yvelines avait coché ce
rendez-vous dans leur agenda on écoute
la vice-présidente du club morgan
goulard dirigeante était au micro de
nicolas d'ambré c'est un niveau
départemental donc les gelées fille
viennent juste de reprendre
l'entraînement il ya trois mois
et encore des petites choses à caler ses
bas encore hyperassur etc mais mais
c'est une première échéance et ça permet
au foot de se tester en début de saison
le jem et l'encours maurepas organisera
également début avril et demi finales du
championnat de france au palais des
sports d'el en cours handball les filles
de mon team retenu n'arrête plus de
gagner dans le championnat de nationale
2 elles viennent d'enchaîner une
troisième victoire consécutive contre
aubervilliers sur le score de 26 à 23
une performance qui leur permet de
remonter à la 9e place du classement
dépassant leurs adversaires du jour
prochain match le 4 février à domicile
contre le paris saint germain toujours
en balles mais cette fois ci en
prénationale ont joué ce week-end la 10e
journée du championnat
très bonne opération pour les clubs
évinois plaisir s'est imposé contre la
métropolitaine des transports 25 à 21
dans son côté versailles est allé
s'imposer contre châtenay malabry 33 30
au classement les plaisirs oies sont
toujours au coude à coude avec reuil
pour la première place versailles est
sixième à huit points du podium
un mot de boxe à présent l'avait quitté
en avril dernier a battu après sa
défaite contre le britannique cal aux
smiths une contre-performance qui lui
est dû qui lui a fait perdre sa ceinture
de champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens l'élan courtois a dit lahm
houmadi est de retour sur les rings ce
samedi il défiera l'ukrainien chez
l'élève pour se relancer nous avons
rencontré le boxeur de la team farruggia
juste après son entraînement
nous sommes au sdis center de maurepas
yunus avec l'ancien champion d'europe
des poids super moyens a dit la hamouma
dix membres de la team farrugia à
elancourt bonjour bonjour alors avant de
parler de votre futur combat qui va se
dérouler dans quelques jours nous allons
parler de boue a dit là vous avez
combattu en avril dernier contre kaloum
suisse ne s'était pas très bien passé
vous aviez perdu depuis vous n'avez pas
combattu comment vous sentez vous
physiquement depuis avril dernier
physiquement je me sens plutôt bien on a
bien récupéré on s'entraîne comme il
faut et puis
on est pas les objectifs je pas les
objectifs alors vous allez affronter
l'ukrainien ruslan celle fc si je vais
bien prononcé le 17 décembre prochain à
doazit aux grands c'est ça c'est un
combat important pour vous d'avoir très
important oui c'est un moment important
parce que ça ça va être le premier
combat que j'ai effectué après cette
défaite en angleterre donc du tout c'est
relativement important parce que c'est
un combat qu'il pourra aussi classé dans
mr dans les rangs donc on ne prend pas
la légion vous l'avez pas pris à la
légère également au niveau
l'entraînement vous êtes entraîné
durement pour leur parler durement pour
ce combat et fille
certain temps donc où on est présent
deux fois par jour on est présent là
c'est pareil à une préparation de combat
par exemple par comme il y avait eu pour
kalou smith c'est à peu près du même
ordre c'est à peu près du même ordre
c'est à dire ça se décompose comment ils
séances d'entraînement par exemple pour
le matin ça va être axé sur le physique
l'après-midi tactique aux tactiques bien
sensations au niveau 1 au niveau du ring
avec les gants des leçons des travaux à
thème il il ya plein de choses pour
retrouver justement toutes ses
sensations du ring et cherchait hier par
la source csu craignent un seul élève il
a un bilan de 13 victoires 6 défaites
il sera dur à aller chercher ou penser
que c'est plutôt accessible dans tous
les cas c'est toujours très dur
chaque combat ne se ressemblent pas
après l'ukrainien il a une boxe y est
particulière où il avance du premier au
huitième rhône dont qui sera pas là pour
faire de la figurine moi non plus ça va
être je pense un très bon
majorque en masse pour vous l'objectif
c'est peut-être de se rassurer me
rassurer surtout m'évaluer laval vais
voir ce que ça va donner puis en prendre
du positif comme négatif sur ce dernier
combat sur ce prochain combat phare de
votre objectif peut-être par rapport ce
combat c'est le terminer rapidement ou
le faire durer pour avoir ces sensations
là qui vous manque le nantais serait
surtout de faire le faire durer trouver
ses sensations si ça doit se terminer
avant ça servira avant mais le monde
objectif ne sera pas spécialement axé
là-dessus ça sera vraiment plus dans un
premier temps de pouvoir faire le combat
de prendre le moins de coups possible de
mettre en difficulté pas spécialement de
me retrouver en difficulté pouvoir
réaliser tout ce qu'on a pu travailler à
la salle par exemple et de prendre
peut-être du plaisir également surtout
il ya forcément si je suis ainsi nommée
en tête déjà de monter sur le ring c'est
vraiment déjà dans un premier temps pour
prendre du plaisir c'est qu'on vous pose
souvent la question vous avez 36 ans est
ce qu a dit lahm ou mady a encore fort
victoire toujours parce que l'objectif
n'est pas encore atteint le en tout cas
cet objectif qu'on se met et d'ailleurs
je croyais en alu en parlait déjà
peut-être avant qu'elle au smic
oui c'est julie zoo mois
un monde on y est on y est pas encore
alors l'objectif est toujours ancré dans
une petite partie de ma tête
donc j'ai encore tant que je suis pas
arrivé à l'objectif encore ce prochain
combat justement ça sera une première
étape
on va arriver voilà à ce titre futur
peut-être de championnat ça donc ça sera
peut-être un combat qui pourrait même
remonter dans les classements mondiaux
ensuite en refaire un second où un
troisième qui j'ai par la suite une
ceinture et puis ça va se décanter comme
ça pour moi
sur l'année 1 sur l'année pouvoir
j'aimerais en tout cas cette année du
moins pour 2010 est boxé plus
régulièrement
d'accord vous n'avez plus le temps voilà
fallait vite
et voilà et si on peut le faire en
france à 100 quand ça sera encore mr
merci beaucoup a dit bon courage
bon bah je le rappelle le téléspectateur
le combat ce sera le samedi à 17
décembre à noisy le grand
on passe maintenant dans l'agenda du
week-end
on commence à trouver par du kickboxing
plus de 90 jeunes âgés de 5 à 8 ans
pourront tester ces disciplines de boxe
pieds-poings ce week end une coupe de
noël est organisé ce dimanche à partir
de 13 heures complexe sportif jean
moulin bois d'arcy
si vous voulez assister à ce rendez-vous
l'entrée est libre il y aura également
du tir à l'arc ce week-end les archives
de guyancourt organisent leur concours
annuel au gymnase maurice baquet ce
samedi à partir de midi et dimanche à
partir de 8h 30 sébastien peineau
champion du monde individuel et par
équipe en turquie à ankara en 2016 sera
présent pour l'événement c'est la fin de
ce statut de sport merci d'avoir suivi
je retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine à 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive
[Musique]